في افغانستان تعليم النساء وعملهن ممنوع
بقوه قانون طالبان خطوه جرت على الحركه
انتقادات دوليه واسعه حتى من حكومات تمارس
انواع القمع والتسلط على النساء كالنظام
الايراني الجهود الدوليه والمطالب بالغاء
القرار متواصله القائم باعمال رئيس بعثه
الامم المتحده الى افغانستان حتى القائمه
باعمال وزير الاقتصاد في حكومه طالبان على
الغاء خطوه حظر عمل موظفه منظمه غير
الحكوميه بعثه الامم المتحده للمساعده في
افغانستان قالت في بيان ان ملايين الافغان
بحاجه الى المساعده الانسانيه ومن الضروري
تذليل العقبه الموجوده وزاره الاقتصاد في
حكومه طالبان سبق ان حدثت جميع المنظمات
غير الحكوميه المحليه منها والاجنبيه بمنع
موظفيها من العمل حتى اشعار اخر
الاوامر لا تنطبق بشكل مباشر على الامم
المتحده لكن المنظمات غير الحكوميه التي
يشملها القرار تتولى تنفيذ الكثير من
برامج الامم المتحده ما يهدد بازمه اخرى
ستواجه النساء والاسره الافغانيه لتضاف
الى كل الازمات التي يعاني منها الشعب
الافغاني بلال البوجدين العربي